hi everyone my name is thomas miller i'm
a final year phd student in astrophysics
at the university of southampton
and today i'm going to tell you about
cultural process which is a tool that i
use in my research
what is gaussian process custom process
is a basic method for data regression or
classification
in general people use gaussian processor
for data regression
however the concept behind regression
and classification is
the same now it assumes that the data
are a set of random variables that
distribute as a multivariate normal
distribution
there's a lot a lot of information in
here so let's break this down
let's focus first on the second point in
here let's assume
we have this set of this data set in
here
with the y values and error bars
now the assumption is that each of these
data points
is going to have a normal distribution
so what this cell is telling us is that
a y value it has a certain probability
where the the mean of the value is gonna
have the highest probability given the
normal distribution discussion
distribution that we see here on the
right
we're gonna call that mu so that's the
mean
of the gaussian and it's going to have a
certain width which is going to be two
sigma
two standard deviation so that's going
to be our uncertainty
in the y value so
another way of looking at this is that
the probability
of observing y given x distributes as a
normal distribution
with a mean of mu and
a standard deviation of sigma
and this is true for all the other data
points in here
or that's the assumption at least um
jointly they distribute as a
multivariate normal distribution
now going back to the first point in
here let's remember
a base theorem so that's what we have in
here
both equations are the same just written
in slightly different ways
so the left part of the equation we have
the posterior which is the probability
of
our function of sorry of our model
being the true latent uh function that
described
that describes our observations and on
the right we have the
likelihood which is the probability of
our y values giving the x values and our
model
now we know that this likelihood
this is just going to be our normal
distribution our gaussian distribution
because that's the assumption behind
behind gaussian process
so that's very simple to estimate now
the prior is just some prior knowledge
that we have on our model
or in this case on the parameters of our
model
let's say we know that the models cannot
have some negative values
so that's some prior knowledge that we
incorporate in here
and evidence is just the probability of
what the y value given
x value and in general we focus on the
likelihood and
prior because we want to maximize the
posterior
so the probability of our model being
the true model that describes the data
and for that we need to maximize the
likelihood
and the posterior is going to make the
predictions afterwards
so if we want to predict a new data
point that we haven't seen before
so let's say interpolate or extrapolate
that's what what
the posterior is going to be doing
now caution process model consists of a
main function
and a covariance matrix also called
kerner
in main function it can be anything can
be constant
can be a straight line whatever you want
and
the covariance matrix well the kernel
can have
different forms this is just one example
this is the
square exponential kernel which looks
like this
and it has two main parameters so
it has the variance and the length scale
what this covariance matrix or kernel is
telling us is just the correlation
between
a set of or two data points so if you
have two data points very close together
then the correlation is going to be
quite high
but if the distance between the relative
distance between two data points
is very large then the correlation
between poles is going to be very low
however the exact shape of this function
of this curve that we see in here
is going to depend on the kernel but
also the parameters inside the kernel
now in this video it's gonna i'm gonna
show you how
how gaussian process works in practice
and yeah to start with we we have a mean
function equal to zero
but when we start adding data points
we see how the gaussian process starts
to learn where to go
so this is the data-driven part the data
is telling the gaussian process where to
go
and well with a given uncertainty that
depends
on the kernel and the covariance matrix
so you can see how we can make
predictions we can
interpolate and extrapolate with
gaussian process
and uh so let's
go with the coding part there are lots
of packages out there for
to implement gaussian processing python
this one
george is just one of the many i like
this one because it's very intuitive
it's very easy to use and yeah
so to start with we import
the main libraries that we're going to
use the main packages for example
for plotting for working with arrays and
we import george
for gaussian process and for this
example we're going to generate
generate some mock data so we have our
latent function our true function this
is a periodic
function in this case and we have our
simulated observations
with a given uncertainty
now here we just need a few lines of
code to
to have a gaussian process prediction so
first we need express which is the
x values where we want the prediction to
be
then we have the variance and length
scale which in this case i chose some
arbitrary values and we defined here our
kernel
so we have the variance here and we have
the
length scale which is given to this um
this kernel function inside george
and then here we create our gaussian
process object
and we fit the kernel into this object
then we
pre-compute the covariance matrix given
the x
values and the uncertainties in the
observations
then we just predict and for the
prediction we
need the y values of the observations
and the x values where we want the
prediction to be
and this will return the prediction in
the y value and the
uncertainty with it
and here we have on the right we plot
our prediction on top of the
observations on the latent
function you can see that the prediction
does quite well
this in general the latent function is
within one sigma
throughout most of the of the range in
here which is quite good
however the kernel the best kernel
depends on each case
for example here we could have used a
a cosine kernel which would have done a
much better job
and we can also for example optimize the
parameters here
which would also improve the prediction
so i hope with this you have a better
idea of how gaussian process works
uh how to implement it with python so
gaussian puzzle is an excellent
patient method for data regression um
the gaussian process model consists of a
main function that can be any function
that you want
is usually a constant and a covariance
matrix
called kernel which well there are lots
of kernels that you can use a lot of
functions
that you can use the best kernel is case
dependent
so if you have some prior knowledge
about your data set then
the better because you can choose the
best kernel and you
have to keep in mind this um this big
assumption that your data set
distributes as a multi-normal
distribution which is usually the case
but not always so if you have some prior
knowledge about your data set that's
very useful
um yeah so there are lots of packages
for implementing gaussian process
george is just one of the many thank you
very much